that's why what these students these
survivors are doing this week are doing
now have been doing since this tragedy
that's why what they're doing is so
important they're organizing they're
saying no more I'm not gonna bury any
more of my classmates nobody in this
country should have to bury any more of
their classmates or their brothers and
sisters no more parents should have to
bury their children because they were
killed in school and you can blame
mental health you can do what Fox News
is doing and Republicans and saying it's
the family dynamic it's it's the video
games it's the movies it's Hollywood but
at the end of the day it's the guns and
I know they say guns don't kill people
keep people kill people but you know
what people kill people with guns with
an ar-15 capable of firing 45 shots a
minute no civilian in the United States
should have that weapon ever there is no
reason for it there is no excuse for it
and if you try to rationalize that then
you're a part of the problem but these
students these survivors from this high
school in parkland Florida have
organized they've staged lions at the
White House and in front of the White
House they're on Twitter they're
fighting back they're fighting against
people like Tomi larren and the other
idiots on Fox News who want to tell us
that no this isn't a gun issue you guys
are just trying to take away our Second
Amendment rights
you're politicizing this tragedy now's
not the time to talk about it no this is
the time to talk about it while people
are angry while people do have the
energy in the motivation to go out there
and do something that is the best time
to do it while this anger is still fresh
while the blood money that Republicans
have received from the NRA is still
dripping while it's out there in the
public yeah this is the time and what
these students are doing is 100% the
right thing to do and it is what is
necessary to do hopefully something
happens because of this
because it's one thing to go out there
and try to you know argue against a
parent against an adult but these are
children whose friends are gone and III
know the parents also are out there
fighting as well but it's really hard
for Fox News to fight back against
children but that hasn't stopped him
this morning
right-wing media outlets all being
retweeted and liked by Donald Trump jr.
mind you have begun smearing one of the
most vocal activists from Parkland who
is helping with the organization of
these events to tell Congress to do
something about gun violence and gun
control they're smearing him as the son
of an FBI agent and they're trying to
say that he's trying to cover up for the
fact that the FBI botched the response
and the prevention of this tragedy so
Fox News who's not Fox News but
conservative medium and and Fox News
with it they found a way to attack the
children to attack the the friends and
families of the victims they've already
found a way I don't know that it's gonna
work this time I think we've put too
many children too many family members in
the ground for these attacks to take
hold anymore did the FBI miss some
warning signs yeah they did and that is
unfortunate but at the end of the day if
this kid didn't have his hands on an
ar-15 this couldn't happened or any
other high-capacity rifle since I know
Republicans loved to argue the
terminology rather than focus on the
issue
if this kid didn't have a weapon capable
of firing dozens of rounds per minute to
maximize killing this wouldn't have
happened we've had an assault weapons
ban in the United States before it
didn't solve all our problems but they
were nowhere near as bad as they are
today they were nowhere near as bad as
they are since that ban expired in 2004
because Bush and his cronies didn't want
to renew it
we were fine as a country when we had
that ban in place
nobody's second Amendment rights were
infringed the only thing that was
hurting were the profits of the gun
manufacturers but now their profits are
soaring you know who else's profits are
soaring the people who make small
coffins
I'm fairing cousins I'm for David Pakman
today got to take a quick break
you can follow me on twitter at fair and
balanced you can check me out on line at
TR o feiyr.com
and we'll be right back